so my I got to start with my the biggest
complaint I have with the movie and that
is it's not 4 hours I needed it to be
longer um and I I was asking Deni about
deleted scenes and he told me I'm never
going to see them so I'm asking you guys
directly what was the thing in the movie
part one or part two and part two did
you have any scene that didn't make the
final cut that you're a little sad that
didn't get in not in this one I honestly
think everything I shot is in there in
the first part there was a sort of a
training sequence with Lady Jessica it
was uh sort of U it began with a
meditation and there was a candle that
uh we were we were practicing the voice
on and uh it was just sort of eerie
almost psychedelic scene and we both had
you know our costumes and even our hair
I think was different than it was the
rest of the film it had all the
Hallmarks of something that was going to
get cut but um uh but it was it was just
it was just an like I said an eerie
psychedelic scene that didn't make it in
there yeah I want to see that now I I
think I I think most of what we shot is
in the film I mean there's other takes
we we did so many versions of things so
I'm I'd be so curious to see other
versions but uh I love it so much just
as it is oh no it's fantastic so one of
the things I commend you both on in the
fight scene between you guys is that
I've seen so many action set pieces
where there's a quick cut every
millisecond and it makes me insane cuz
it's clear that
what I love about your sequence is that
you can see you guys it's not every
millisecond to cut so can you sort of
talk about the importance of doing it
yourself and making it believable so the
audience you know believes in what
you're selling um yeah I mean we were so
fortunate to have the greatest stunt
team in the world and and uh and and so
we both trained for months before we
even met and before we were in Hungary
and uh and trained in collie with a guy
named Alvin and and la and then Roger
Yuan came on board and uh started
started getting more and more specific
with us about what the fight was going
to be and um and it went through many
different incarnations in a way that
fight and and then um and then our first
meeting was in the stunt room and and
then we we fought immediately and uh and
so we just knew that that this was going
to be this thing that that was really
vital and um and I mean that's that's
kind of what we bonded and I saw how
hard Timothy had worked on it and
um and yeah and so it just it we wanted
to bring out the best in each other and
and try to kill each other without
actually hurting each other you know
sure yeah what is it like delivering a
monologue in another language yeah
thrilling I mean um that was uh probably
the the couple of days on set I was
looking forward to the most uh because I
you're in a movie of this size and even
playing uh one of the lead characters uh
you you
the the the film and the story is so
much greater than than Paul in many ways
even if it's it's Paul's Journey at the
center of it so on the days where it's
really front and center and where I've
seen Austin who shot the Gladiator
sequence up front uh and the production
schedule and I see the playbacks to that
and how how well or how amazingly he
crushed it you know and and uh seeing
Charlotte rampling do great work in Lay
do in Florence which he shot in Italy
and now I got to step up to the plate
here and uh and just incredibly
affirming and all the more bizarre to do
it in a language that doesn't exist you
know and have it memorized in English
too we did it in English as well but you
know then he chose the chopa which I
liked I thought that was so much cooler
even if it's subtitled you know uh I
think it's just a stronger
Choice 100% so your look in the film is
very unique how much did you want to
leave set and just go to a coffee shop
in that out with the way you looked and
just be anonymous and so badly how great
would that be I'm being completely
serious like I would have wanted to
leave set because also no one would
realize it's you no no yeah especially
with the teeth and everything oh my God
it's fantastic so and if you're really
friendly yeah yeah super friendly like
um tip right I actually want to ask an
individual question so you've played
Willie Wonka Paula trades and you're
about to play Bob Dylan which of those
roles really when you found out you were
going to get them really kept you up at
night in terms of oh my effing God I'm
about to do this all three all three
there's something about um when you
embark on a story that uh is 100%
original and you're really shining your
flashlight into the dark and just going
and willly wono Paulo tradies and Bob
Dylan these are like dangerous
characters to go here because I said a
lot on the Willy Wonka press tour people
are rightfully very protective of them
because they already exist in a
significant cultural if not emotional
place for many people and they don't
want you to go near it you know
understandably I feel like that about
some roles um or characters in you know
in public imagination but
uh what's the end of that thought but I
guess I guess I'm still going to do them
yeah
bre